has it been a whole week since we talked
about spider-man no way home
what what is this craziness spider
warren today
has put out a video no way home leaked
fight scene details toby mcguire news
and
trailer update loki's ending this week
if what if it's coming out in three
weeks
it's gotta come out at some point in
between there right
in time it only makes sense we even see
spider-man in the what-if trailer
come on grasping for straws here people
in the dr strange cape on the poster
itself
yeah about time come on do it
[Music]
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and we
have some pretty big spider-man no way
home news today
we're getting pretty close to the movies
release date and hopefully getting
pretty close to that trailer releasing
and as we get closer and closer more
leaks are going to
inevitably get out and today we actually
have some pretty good
leaks we have some leaks about three
different scenes that are going to be
taking place during spider-man no way
home
involving some pretty cool rematches
that i know a lot of fans are going to
be really excited to see
then one new fight that of course fans
are going to be excited for as well we
also have one leak that gives us more
confirmation that toby maguire
spider-man will be in the movie
and then it looks like we might actually
have a time frame for when to
expect the trailer like i said a lot to
dive into today so let's get into it
if any trailer update just makes me
laugh at this position
but it has to come before diving into a
scene that toby mcguire is going to have
in spiderman no way home
let's talk about something that has
happened recently that gives us further
evidence
that he is indeed going to be in this
film toby mcguire's spider-man spanish
voice dub actor roger pera has seemingly
confirmed that he
is going to be working on spider-man no
way home
on instagram he was recently asked if he
was going to be dubbing toby spider-man
again
in which he replied with sort of a
two-part answer one he
zipped his lips but then he gave us a
thumbs up
seemingly confirming that yes he is
that's a pretty piece of evidence right
there i have like no commentary on that
that is so
that's so telling i think he is the best
that's the best response i've
seen thus far he's saying can't say
anything but yes
and if he's the same but yes that's what
a thumbs up means if he wasn't all he
had to say was
no the fact that he's given that is just
the biggest confirmation now some of you
guys are going to be like oh i can't
wait for you to be mephisto or
disappointed this is just way too
apparent damn
damn that does seem incredibly
straightforward just like yeah i'm gonna
be voicing him i'm his voice actors this
is what i'm gonna be doing in fact last
time it looked like he kind of got into
some trouble for saying anything about
it
earlier this year
this is much better in which they asked
him a similar question if he is going to
be working on any spider-man film soon
in which he responded that he was indeed
going to be working
on a film soon this was posted to their
youtube channel in which
very shortly after the part where he
answers this question
was removed it was edited out which you
truly
you still can edit
being in the film because if he's not in
the film why would his spanish and
portuguese voice actor be in the film
especially because he doesn't do the
work for tom holland spider-man or
andrew garfield spider-man
just toby's i think this is also as a
voice actor this is the most recognition
he's gonna be getting
so like probably seeing his face they're
being drawn to him they're wanting to
ask him questions
i can see why he's probably playing into
it and he's like screw it so more
evidence that toby maguire is going to
be in the film
and of course that also gives us more
evidence that andrew garfield will be in
the film as well
and speaking of those two like i
mentioned in the beginning
we have some leaks today involving this
he's got a number two tom holland
spider-man now there seems to be a
common theme
with several of the leaks that have come
out pretty recently and i have heard
from some people
and some people have been posting online
recently that there is a pretty big plot
leak out there that
is true specifically one part
and that specific part is about doctor
strange somehow
capturing the villains from the other
universes and keeping them in some sort
of a magical prison inside of the
sanctum
from there apparently doctor strange and
tom hall and spider-man will have a bit
of a disagreement
this disagreement is presumably about
doctor strange keeping these villains
locked up and from here it seems like
our peter parker is going to be
responsible for releasing these villains
now how tall mcguire's spider-man and
how andrew garfield spider-man get into
the picture
that's still unclear whether doctor
strange brings them in for help or the
multiverse somehow
sucks them out of their own universes
and spits them out into ours
we're not sure about that yet and thanks
to the account superhero theorists that
i've mentioned on here before
we have a little bit of insight on a few
scenes that we can expect from
toby maguire spider-man andrew garfield
spider-man and our very own tom holland
spider-man
what i'm imagining is kind of like a
terminator situation when they're
plucked over here maybe they just don't
all appear in the same location but
they're kind of spread out or scattered
definitely see that
you know or like into the spider verse
or venom yeah
you know just watch a big long travel
montage up until the third act
according to superhero theorists we are
going to be getting three fight scenes
and two of these are going to be
rematches from previous movies the first
one of course
is going to be toby maguire's peter
parker and doc
ock we had some pretty amazing iconic
fights in spider-man 2
specifically that train scene and it
looks like we're going to be getting at
least
one more iconic fight between them as
well then according to this report
declare iconic too early on between
andrew garfield's peter parker and
electro now we could use that we kind of
knew we're going to happen
we're going to have another showdown and
that's going to be with
our peter parker tom holland and an
amazing spider-man character
now at this point in time so many
characters have been rumored to be in
this film we're not exactly sure who
they could be referring to
but there's no two things one is that
that was essentially
the most sinister six in this movie a
sinister six consisting of villains from
all of the universes not just ours not
just from the spider-man samurai
universe and not just from the amazing
spider-man universe but all of them
combined we've learned that sandman is
going to be in this yeah and we've also
learned daniel rpk
confirmed a couple months i mean
supposedly confirmed i believe it
that lizard's supposed to be in this yes
so it's either sandman or lizard if
we're talking about amazing spider-man
characters it could only be the lizard
then oh yeah that's right it's an
amazing spider-man because otherwise
it seems like the toby maguire movie is
getting the most love in terms of
bringing villains over so yeah it only
leaves lizard and hey maybe that could
uh
open up another opportunity for a peter
mentor gone wrong the three different
spider-man will team up together to
fight the sinister six
and the main villain behind it all is
going to be the green goblin
and based off of everything that we've
heard so far the green goblin
is going to be willem dafoe's green
goblin from the sam raimi spider-man
universe
he is seemingly going to be the leader
of the sinister six and there's also
rumors that we could actually have
our own norman osborne appear in the
movie as well and he could
actually be good there has been a leak
and although this isn't one of those
leaks that has been confirmed to be true
it does state that the other norman
osborne from the sam raimi universe is
going to kill
our norman osborne and if that were to
come true that could have
huge implications for the future of our
marvel cinematic universe
especially if we've learned anything
from loki and i don't think that the tva
is going to be around for much longer to
correct things and speaking of
like i mean it looks like we may have a
time frame of
when to expect the spider-man trailer
that's so
true because the tv i mean if you guys
are watching as a spider-man but if
you're
watching loki tvas and shambles right
now that's all
i'll say yeah nexus event like this one
is going to go unchecked
yeah exactly
[Music]
i didn't even think about that that's
why the multiverse of madness can come
become madness because absolutely the tv
why did i
go there with all these movies right the
long game of marvel
and this is also coming from superhero
theorist who has never actually
mentioned
anything about a trailer release date
before but somebody tweeted i'm guessing
the trailer is coming before the
premiere of what if and he responded
with
oh yeah before that now what if comes
out on august
11th so if this is true it's going to be
coming out before that which means we
have
less than a month the loki series is
what's really introducing the multiverse
to us
and more than likely in just a couple of
days now the show is most likely going
to end
with the tva being taken down and
destroyed the tva was
responsible for killing essentially
branched timelines
basically their job is to prevent the
multiverse and with the loki finale most
likely ending with the tva
out of the picture for good that's going
to set up spider-man no way home and
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness
and this is what needs to happen before
we see the spider-man no way home
trailer
that way people could have a good grasp
on what the multiverse actually
is and that way variants of a character
aren't really that confusing
i mean we've seen at least 20 loki's by
now so seeing three spider-man on screen
shouldn't be that big of a deal although
it's going to be
the biggest deal ever but thanks to loki
people shouldn't be confused so if this
report is true about the trailer coming
out before what if on august 11th
it makes perfect sense because loki had
to finish first
let's just hope it's true but let me
know what you think about all of these
leaks in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe and hit the notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos
for live updates you can always follow
me on instagram and twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching
we'll fall off guys gonna be putting
together
a little sketch that hopefully does not
turn into five minutes
that's play before the trailer reaction
got a lot of work to get to
it's just for you guys i hope we can get
it done and i hope that video is
monetized because i don't know what
music will be in that trailer
spider-man no way home thank you warren
for putting that video together got some
juicy information from there subscribe
to cosmic wonder if you haven't done so
already subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell hit
like buttons galore last but not least
jt from hawaii the guy in the chair
our fearless idea day buddy i don't know
it's the summer time it's been hot as
heck out here
and it's just made me think of how much
nicer it probably is
out where you are in hawaii i wish we
could take a
break and come visit you just chill out
on the sands
you know get a tan together just like
let
our majestic bodies soak up the rays
of golden hawaiian sunlight man i feel
like
that would be the most relaxing thing
possible you are probably our most
relaxing patron
i can think of and whenever i think of
you i just feel a little more serene
inside you know especially even in this
moment just thinking about you
and your room and just like your
collectibles all around and your good
natured way of like considering people
as they speak
taking your time to form a response and
then being oh so thoughtful in the
process
jt
you